اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض معكم ابرز المستجدات نبدا
بالعناوين
يتحدى الروس ويقول ان المقاتلات الامريكيه
ستحلق فخو فوق البحر الاسود تتوعد
وسط تحذيرات دوليه قرابه الطنين ونصف الطن
من اليورانيوم تختفي من ليبيا والحكومه لا
تعلق
تفشي عدوى انهيار سيلكون فالي بنك كريدي
سويس سيقترض 54 مليار دولار من المركز
السويسري
لليوم التالي على التوالي جلسه استجواب
لحاكم مصرف لبنان رياض سلامه بعد تغيبه عن
الحضور
البدايه من السجل الامريكيه الروسيه حول
التحليق في اجواء البحر الاسود اذ اكد
وزير الدفاع الامريكي
ان بلاده ستواصل القيام برحلات استطلاعيه
والعمل حيثما يسمح القانون الدولي ووصف
حادثه اسقاط الطائره الامريكيه المسيره في
البحر الاسود بالحلقه الخطيره موضحا انها
جزء من نمط من الاجراءات العدوانيه
والمحفوفه بالمخاطر وغير الامنه من قبل
الطيارين الروس في المجال الجوي الدولي
واشار وزير الدفاع الامريكي الى انه من
واجب روسيا تشغيل طائراتها العسكريه
بطريقه امنه ومهنيه من جانبه قال الجنرال
مارك ميلي رئيس هيئه الاركان المشتركه
الامريكيه ان القوات الروسيه حققت تقدما
طفيفا في بخمت لكن بتكلفه بشريه هائله
مشيرا الى ان هناك جهودا مستمره لبناء
الجيش الاوكراني ومساعدته للدفاع عن
اوكرانيا
في الوقت الحالي هناك قتال عنيف في باخ
موتو محيطها الروس يحققون تقدما تكتيكيا
صغيرا لكن بتكلفه باهظه بينما لا يزال
الخط الامامي ثابتا نسبيا مع تبادل كبير
للقصف المدفعي دون تحقيق مكاسب هناك جهود
كبيره ومستمره لبناء الجيش الاوكراني من
حيث المعدات والذخيره والتدريب في مجموعه
من البلدان بهدف تمكين اوكرانيا من الدفاع
عن نفسها
في امريكا
ان الهجوم على طائرات الروسيه في مجال جوي
محايد هو اعلان حرب مفتوحه ضد اكبر قوه
نوويه اكد ايضا ان الصراع بين روسيا
وامريكا سيكون مختلفا بشكل جذري عن الحرب
غير المباشره بين البلدين في اوكرانيا احل
هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من موسكو
الدبلوماسي الروسي السابق في اهلا بك
السيد في يعني بين الروايه الامريكيه
والروايه الروسيه يعني ما تقييمك
للمعلومات التي قدمتها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هل تراها منطقيه وفعليا هل
انتهت المساله ام انه التداعيات مستمره
تداعيات هذا الحادث
جواب الرسمي على طلب وزاره الخارجيه
امريكيه اعطى الى صفير الروسي في واشنطن
واليوم صباحا
كذلك اكد هذا القول وهو دافع على انه هذا
التعازم علاقات بين الدول الكبرى الدول
النوويه التي ناتجه من
تحليق طائرات مسيره على امريكيه
المنطقه الات تجري هناك عمليه عسكريه
بمشاركه جيش الروسي ليش هكذا يعتبرون في
روسيا
مشاركه مباشره بولايات المتحده في هذه
العمليه العسكريه
على جنب الطرف المعادل ولذلك
نزره على سابته انه امريكا بعيده ان
امريكا لا تشارك حرب في اوكرانيا
انتهت
والان ينظر على كل وجود الطيران مسيره او
غير مسيره في هذا المنطقه لا شاركا سوف
يعتبر ان هذا وجود الطيران يعني هذه
المسيره الامريكيه سيد فيسلافيا فوق مياه
دوليه
اكد بان ذلك سيستمر وبالتالي يمكن ان تحدث
هذه الحادثه مره اخرى صحيح ولكن بحر
الاسود وهذا واضح تماما اهداف لهذه
الطياره مسيره هل المنطقه اعلنوا كم منطقه
يجري فيها
مغلق الجو
ليست بحرا وجوا كذلك امريكان يهمل هذا ولا
ياخذ بان نتيجه
المعلومات استخباراتيه من ناقص طياره
المسيره السابقا اغرقوا
الباخره عسكريه الروسيه موسكو في بحر
الاسود ولذلك
روسيا تنظر على هذا المناورات
في حدود مع المنطقه
يجري فيها المعارك مصالحه بين جيش الروسي
وجيش مؤيد من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه جيش اوكراني الذي
من امريكا
عمليه عدائيه ولكن ما مصير الحطام الان
الحطام المسيره الامريكيه الروس بالمنطق
هم اقرب الى ايجاده لانه ليس هنالك اي
سفينه امريكيه قريبه
بالبحر الاسود هل ستسلمه برايك روسيا الى
واشنطن
انا اتصور ان لا تتجاوب روسيا خطوه بخطوه
عين بالعين اما سوف يوجع الطريق مناسبه
مناسبه
لامكانيات العسكريه الروسيه امكانيات
السياسيه او
امكانياتها يعني عسكريه ولذلك ليس هناك
جوابا سيكون ولكن سوف يستمر ان
يكحلقه في هذا المنطقه
معلن رسميا منطقه يجرك فيها الحرب
نعم ابقى معي السيده فيس لاف سنتابع معك
هذا الحديث
من منطقه
اصلا يحبه موقف روشين لا يحبك ولكن يفهمه
استدام مع الطيرات مسيره في هذا المنطقه
هذا اصطدام مع القوات المسلحه الروسيه
امريكا وروسيا دول النوويه هذا هو استنتاج
لكانت اليوم ابقى معي سيد فاش سلاف اذا
سنذهب الى بعض الاخبار الميدانيه واعود
اليك حيث فجر رئيس مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه
الروسيه قنبله من العيار الثقيل مع دعوته
الى السماح للمواطنين الروس بانتقاد كبار
القاده العسكريين بعد اقرار مجلس النواب
قانونا يشدد العقوبات على من يشوهون سمعه
القوات التي تحارب في اوكرانيا وقال ان
الناس يجب ان يمتلكوا حريه التعبير عن
ارائهم معتبرا ان الجنود مقدسين وحدهم
ويجب ان يكونوا بمعزل عن الانتقاد على حد
وصفه مضيفا ان قانون مكافحه تشويه السمعه
يجب الا يسري على اركان القياده
تعمل المستشار العسكريه البريطانيه
القاده العسكريين الروس بالتخلي عن
الوحدات العسكريه وتبديد الموارد
الاستراتيجيه لتحقيق مكاسب تكتيكيه صغيره
واوضح ان روسيا تعاني من خسائر فادحه ادت
لمقتل واصابه ما يصل الى 30 الف عسكري
روسي من الجيش ومن قوات فاجنر في محيط
باخموت وحدها وذلك بمقابل التقدم لحوالي
25 كم فقط وقالت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه
ان محاولات الجيش الروسي للسيطره على بلده
فوليزار بيدونيات تباطات بشكل كبير
الاسبوع الماضي بعد هجمات وصفاتها
بالفاشله والمكلفه للغايه طيله ثلاثه اشهر
واضافت في تحليلها اليومي ان الدفاعات
الاوكرانيه في فوليدار تبنت بنجاح انظمه
مضاده للدروع اجبرت الجيش الروسي على سحب
دباباته وسط حاله من الفوضى واشارت الى ان
الجيش الروسي كان مصمما على دخول فوليدار
لمضاهات تقدم قوات فاجنر في باخموت في
اطار من التنافس بينهما
من موسكو من جديد ينضم الينا الدبلوماسي
الروسي السابق في تسلاف ماتوزاف سيد
فيتسلافي يعني ان يقول رئيس مجموعه
فاجنرخيني بروكين ويدعو الى السماح
للمواطنين الروس بانتقاد القاده العسكريين
باي اطار تضع هذا التصريح ولماذا حتى الان
الكريم لم يرد عليه
اولا ان هناك
التصادم مع قوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
مدعوما من قبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تزداد حده ولا شك انا خلال هذا المعارك
الجاريه في باكموت في
منطقه دنباس وفي الجنوب
اوكرانيا وفي منطقه حركه كل هذا الجبهه لا
تزال هناك تقدم قوات روسيه مستمره يعني
نحن نفهم جيدا ان خلال الحرب هناك حرب
ليست في الميداما بالسلاح ولكن في اعلام
كذلك
ليست بين اوكرانيا وروسيا نحن نتحدث عن
فاجنر القوات المواليه لروسيا التي تنفذ
اجمدتها العسكريه هذه ليست المره الاولى
التي يتم انتقاد فيها الجيش الروسي
والقاده الروس
نواقص لنشات العسكريه لجيش الروسي موجوده
وهذا معترفه بلا اي شاب ولكن خلال الحوض
الحرب اي انتقال
لهؤلاء الذين يقتلون في الميدان هذا شر
ولذلك
برلمان الروسي اقترح عن
يسجلوا القانونيا معاقبه على اي النقد
يعملوا استنتاجات كيف كانت يجري العمليه
عسكريه الفطره ما بعد الحرب ولكن ليست
خلال الحرب الان يتحدثون عن عدد القتلى
عدد الاسره عدد الجرحى احلال الحرب ممنوع
الارقام الصحيحه
لكنك سيد ما توصف لا تجيبني على سؤالي عن
هذا الانشقاق داخل المعسكر الروسي بين
فاجنر والجيش الرسمي
انا اقول لكم ري الشخصي
لا انا كل المعارك في بخموت وتقادم قوات
روسيه كما قالوا الان في هذا
يجري التقدم قوات ليست لجيش الروسي هذا
تقدم لقوات
البحنط كليا يا سيطر فيها فقط عناشر
ولذلك ليست جيش الروسي الذي هو يتقدم
تتقدم فاقنا
وطبعا هناك ريه انا كل شكاوى انه نقصه
الزخائر والصواريخ
ومدفعيه ثقيله ناتجه من
التكتيك تكتيك العسكري لكي يحاول ان يعطوا
اشاره الى
جيش اوكرانيا ان هنا ينقص العدد الزخاير
عدد الصواريخ وقله الجنود وكذلك تعالوا
الى هون لتكافحوا لانه ينتظرون هجوم الجيش
الاوكراني من الجنوب الى البحر ازوك الى
حتى
الاتصال بين روسيا
وبرا على على قرن طبعا روسيا تحاول ان
يجلبوا الاحتياطات العسكريه الاوكرانيه
الى المعركه محمود اكثر يشاركه اكثر يضربه
ولذلك هذا يفشل
مشاريع
الهجوميه لجيش اوكرانيا
خبراء الامريكان على مناطق جنوبيه لذلك
هذا كل حيله العسكريه هذا الشخصي
وهي اكاجيب ان ينقص هناك
صواريخ تعالوا لهون ونحن ضعافات
شكرا جزيلا لك وصلت الفكره سيد فيسلاف
الدبلوماسيروس السابق من موسكو
اعلنت القوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه تكبيد
القوات الروسيه خسائر كبيره خلال معارك
ليليه في بخموت وقالت القوات الخاصه
الاوكرانيه في بيان لها انها تمكنت من
التصدي للهجمات الروسيه على الخطوط
الدفاعيه الاماميه والحفاظ على مواقعها
بدعم من سلاح الجو مشيره الى ان القوات
الروسيه اجبرت على وقف هجماتها بعد مقتل
عدد كبير من الجنود
مره جديده تقول قوه فاجنر الروسيه انها
اقتربت من تطويق مدينه باخموت الاوكرانيه
بالكامل المدينه التي ارتبط اسمها باطول
معركه في تاريخ اوروبا الحديث بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه القوه التي تقود المعركه
في باخموت نشرت صوره توضح السيطرتها على
خمس مدن جديده في محيط المدينه وقالت انها
تواصل المعركه حتى السيطره عليها
بالمقابل يواصل الجيش الاوكراني بالتاكيد
على ثبات قواته في باغموت حيث تشير اخر
الصور القادمه من هناك الى انتشار الجنود
الاوكرانيين في مواقعهم بكامل معداتهم
واجهزتهم الحربيه
والتكنولوجيا وفقا لاحدث المعلومات القوات
الروسيه سيطرت على جميع الطرق المعبده
التي تؤدي الى باخموت ثم يعرقل بشكل كبير
امداد الوحدات الاوكرانيه في المدينه
سيطرت على الجانب الشرقي من المدينه ليصبح
النهر الذي يقسم المدينه الى نصفين خط
المواجهه المباشره بين الطرفين
كذلك اعلنت قوات فاجنر في وقت سابق عن
افتتاح 58 مركزا للتجنيد في المدن الروسيه
فيما يبدو للدفع بمزيد من المقاتلين في
المعركه المصيريه بالنسبه اليها وموسكو
ومع استمرار القتال على جانبي النهر يستمر
الجانبان بالتراشق بالمعلومات والصور
معلومات ما زالت غير مؤكده حتى يثبت العكس
نشرتنا مستمره فيها بعد الفاصل
مفاوضات الجيش الالماني في البرلمان تتقد
جيش بلادها وتقول انه في وضع مسرع
اهلا بكم من جديد انتقلت مفاوضه الجيش في
البرلمان الالماني ايفاغوجل الوتيره
البطيئه لتنفيذ خطه المستشار الالماني
لدعم القوات المسلحه التي اعلنها وعد
الغزو الروسيه لاوكرانيا حيث وصفت هوجن
الوضع المادي للقوات المسلحه بالمزري
والاسوا من العام السابق بل ان الجيش بات
يفتقر الى كل شيء على حد تعبرها ويكابد
الجيش وفق قولها نقصا فعليا بالتجهيز بسبب
ضعف الاداره الالمانيه فمن اصل 100 مليار
تمويل مرصوده لم يتم انفاق اي قرش لصالح
القوات
الحكومه الليبيه المؤقته والمجلس الرئاسي
امتنعوا عن التعليق على اختفاء قرابه
الطنين ونصف الطن من اليونان الطبيعي من
موقع جنوب البلاد لم يعد خاضعا لسيطره
الحكومه واعلنت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه اختفاء عشره اسطوانات تحوي نحو
طنين ونصف من اليورانيوم الطبيعي من موقع
معلن في ليبيا به تركيزات لليورانيوم
الخام واوضحت الوكاله الذريه في بيان ان
ذلك الموقع لا يخضع حاليا لسيطره الهيئه
النوويه الليبيه والفحص كان مقررا العام
الماضي لكنه تاجل لاسباب امنيه الوكاله
اكدت انها ستجري مزيدا من اجراءات التحقق
لاصطلاح ملابسات ازاله هذه المواد وموقعها
الحالي وحضرت الوكاله من ان عدم معرفه
مكان هذه المواد ربما يشكل خطرا اشعاعيا
ويثير كذلك مخاوف تتعلق بالامن النووي
وينضم الينا من عمان عامر الشوبكي الباحث
في شؤون النفط والطاقه اهلا بك سيد عامر
يعني ان تختوي يعني تختفي نحو طنين ونصف
من اليورانيوم الطبيعي من موقع ليبي كيف
يمكن تفسير ذلك يعني كميه ليست بقليله
راويه شكرا على الاستضافه يجب التوضيح
اولا بانه ليس طبيعي هو مرحله متقدمه من
اليورانيوم يسمى الكعكه الصفراء اكسيد
اليورانيوم المركز وهي مرحله تسبق تحويل
الى غاز لوضعه في المسرعات النوويه لتخصيب
بدرجه اكبر الان اليورانيوم المفقود من
ليبيا اثنين ونصف طن بدرجه تركيز يورانيوم
وهذه الكميه اثنين نص طن يعني تقريبا قد
تنتج 300 300 الى 350 كيلوغرام من
اليورانيوم المخصب بدرجه اعلى ثلاثه
بالمئه واربعه بالمئه وهي تصلح كوقود نووي
الان التفسير ربما بيع هذه الكميات خاصه
بانه يعني هذه الكميات درجه اشعاعها غير
غير يعني موجوده وامنه نوعا ما لكن تحتاج
الى نوع من الضبط والتخزين بشكل يعني سليم
ضمن مراقبه وكاله الطاقه الدوليه وهيئه
الطاقه الذريه عفوا واعتقد بان هذا الامر
يعني بسبب الفضه الموجوده في ليبيا نعم
نعم وبالتالي الوكاله الدوليه لتقدريه
حذرت من خطر اشعاعي هل الخطر الاشعاعي
يعني باي درجه وارد وما نطاقه
يعني الاكسيد او مركز اكسيد اليورانيوم
الذي فقد في ليبيا هو بدرجه اشعاع منخفضه
جدا غير مذكوره واعتقد ان الاهميه في
الامر والخطوره في سميت هذه الماده وربما
في استخدامها ايضا في مرحله اخرى في تخصيب
اليورانيوم
وايضا يعني لا بد من وجود ظروف ملائمه
لنقل حتى مثل هذه المواد حتى لا تصبح خطره
على من ينقلها او من حولها او من يصل
اليها نعم ظروف مناسبه لنقلها اذا لم
تتوفر هذه الظروف ما الذي يمكن ان يحصل
نعم هنالك مخاطر من سميت هذه الماده كما
ذكرت لك الاشعاع منخفض جدا
بالكعكه الصفراء او مركز اكسيد اليورانيوم
وهنالك المخاطر على من ينقلها وعلى
المنطقه الموجوده فيها واذا ما القيت
كميات كبيره مثلا في مصادر مياه قد تصبح
ملوثه بشكل كبير للبيئه ومصدر لامراض على
المدى الطويل للافراد والمجتمعات وللسكان
نعم نعم وبالتالي الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه قالت بانه يمكن او ستحاول تحديد
موقع هذه المواد عاده تحديد مكانها كيف
يمكن ان يحصل
نعم يعني وكاله الطاقه الذريه تعمل بنوع
من الجهاز الاستخباري للتحقق من هذه
الكميات اين تذهب واين واين تصل اعتقد بان
الامر ايضا وجد وفي ليبيا
عن هذه الكميات في العام 2003 عندما الغت
برنامجها النووي وكان هنالك ايضا مسرعات
موجوده في الاراضي الليبيه تم تسليمها الى
وكاله الطاقه الذريه عدا عن كميات كانت
مخصبه بدرجات بسيطه ومخططات لصناعه قنبله
ذريه هذا لم يحصل وبقيت هذه الكميه الاقل
ضررا في الاراضي الليبيه اعتقد بانه من
الصعب تحديد مكان هذه الكميه الان ربما
اختلطت مع كميات اخرى موجوده في دول يعني
تنشط في هذا المجال وترقى لان تصل الى
تصنيع الوقود النووي هذه الماده ضروريه
لتصنيع الوقود النووي نعم شكرا جزيلا لك
اذا من عمان عامر الشوبكي الباحث في شؤون
النفطي والطاقه
والان بولندا في هذا الخبر العاجل تعلن
القبض على خليه التجسس روسيه نتابع في
الداخل اللي به ايضا اتفق اعضاء اللجنه
العسكريه المشتركه الليبيه 5 + 5 والمبعوث
الامميه عبد الله اتفقوا على توحيد الجهود
الامنيه ومنع انزلاق الاوضاع نحو الحرب من
جديد وفقا لما افاد به مراسل العربيه فان
قاده الشرق والغرب الليبي
اجتمعوا خلال اجتماعهم بتونس اتفقوا على
اهميه تجريم اعمال العنف والخطف التي تضر
بالسلم الاهلي وحركه المواطنين والبضائع
بين الشرق والغرب كما شدد المجتمعون على
ضروره اقامه الانتخابات قبل نهايه العام
الجاري
قال زعيم الاغلبيه الديمقراطيه في مجلس
الشيوخ الامريكيه تشاك شومر ان المجلس
سيصوت هذا الاسبوع على الغاء تفويضه للحرب
السابقه في العراق قبل ايامنا الذكرى
العشرين لغزو العراق وقال شومر ان الوضع
على الارض تغير كثيرا منذ فتره طويله ويجب
ان تتغير القوانين الموجوده في الكتب ايضا
وهذه احدث محاوله لاعاده تاكيد دور
الكونجرس في اتخاذ قرار بشان ارسال القوات
في مهمه قتاليه ووافقت لجنه العلاقات
الخارجيه بمجلس الشيوخ على مشروع قانون
لالغاء التفويض باستخدام القوى العسكريه
في حربي عام 1991 و20 ضد العراق
دعا كبير الجمهوريين بلجنه العلاقات
الخارجيه لمجلس الشيوخ الامريكي السنافر
الجمريش دعا الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه لتوجيه اللوم لايران بسبب
انتهاكاتها النوويه جاء ذلك خلال اللقاء
السيناتور بمدير الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رفيع الجراسي حيث ناقش الجانبان
عددا من الملفات والقضايا من بينها تخصيب
ايران بنسبه 84% على محطه للطاقه النوويه
في اوكرانيا
اعلن رئيس النظام السوري بشار الاسد انه
سيرحب باي مقترحات من روسيا لاقامه قواعد
عسكريه جديده او زياده عدد قواتها في
سوريا وقال الاسد لوكاله الاعلام الروسيه
بعد محادثات اجراها مع الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين من الوجود العسكريه الروسي
في بلاده لا يتعين ان يكون مؤقتا وقال
الاسد ان روسيا تلعب دورا مهما في الحفاظ
على علاقات جيده بين سوريا وتركيا وهو يثق
بدورها كوسيط لتسهيل الاتصالات بين
البلدين واشترط الاسد انسحاب القوات
التركيه من سوريا للقاء الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان معتبرا ان الانسحاب العسكري
التركي من الاراضي السوريه هو الخيار
الوحيد الذي يمكن ان يحدث بعده الاجتماع
مع اردوغان ووصف رئيس النظام السوري تركيا
بالدوله المحتله وانها لعبت دورا سلبيا
عبر دعم منظمات يعتبرها ارهابيه
مددت محكمه باكستانيه حظر عمليه الشرطه
لاعتقال رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان
يوما اضافيا حتى غد الجمعه وكانت الشرطه
انسحبت من محيط مقر اقامه عمران خان في
لهور بعد اشتباكات مع انصاره وتقول
السلطات ان خان الذي ستبدا محاكمته يوم
السبت سيواجه اتهامات ببيع هدايا تحصل
عليها او تحصل عليها بدوافع سياسيه اثناء
وجوده في منصبه كرئيس للوزراء
من الترقب تسود المنطقه المحيطه بمنزل
رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني السابق عمران خان
بعد اشتباكات متقطعه بين انصاره وقوات
الامن فللمره الثانيه تفشل قوه الامن في
اعتقال عمران خان على خلفيه قضيه فساد
اسره تصدي انصاره لقوات الامن وتعليق
باجراءات اعتقاله مؤقتا بقرار قضائي فيما
الحكومه اتهمت عمران خان باستغلال انصاره
على عمران خان الا يتهرب من الامتثال
للقضاء والشرطه ويختبئ خلف مناصريه فهذا
القضاء نفسه الذي حكم لصالحه لا علاقه
للحكومه بعمل المحاكم والشرطه تنفذ ما
يطلبه منها القضاء
على مدى يومين حاولته
انصار رئيس الوزراء السابق
الى الكفاح من اجل ما وصفه الحريه
الحقيقيه
معتبرا ان مذكرات التوقيف ضده غير قانونيه
ومتهما للحكومه التي وصف اعضائها
بالمحتالين بمحاوله اختطافه او ربما قتله
لن يكون بامكان السيطره على الشباب عندما
يتعرضون لقمع قوات الامن فالاوضاع قد تخرج
عن السيطره اعلق املي على القضاء لقد سجلت
الحكومه ضد 80 بلاغا وقضيه والعدد يزداد
كل ذلك لحرمان من خوض الانتخابات كما اسال
المؤسسه العسكريه ان كان يهمها مصير
البلاد
يعتبر انسحاب قوات الامن من محيط منزله
بمثابه انتصار له مرددينه تافات مؤيده له
ومنوئه للحكومه ومحذرين من محبه اعتقاله
عمران خان هو املنا المتبقي للقضاء على
الفساد والظلم هو يحترم القانون وليست
المشكله في اعتقاله او تسليم نفسه لكن
المشكله ان حياته في خطر ونحن مستعدون
للتضحيه من اجله
عمران خان خط احمر ولن نسمح لحكومه
المستورده والفاسده باعتقاله او التعرض له
فرغما انسحاب قوات الامن وتعليق العمل
مؤقتا بمذكره اعتقاد عمران خان وقدح الطرق
المؤديه لمقر اقامته لا يزال المئات من
انصاره معتصمين بالقرب من منزله للتعبير
عن تضامنهم والتصدي لاي محاوله جديده
لاعتقال عمران خان
في ظل الاستقطاب الحزبي والاتهامات
المتبادله بين الحكومه والمعارضه يحذر
مراقبون من خروج الاوضاع عن السيطره في
وقت تعاني فيه بلاده اوضاعا امنيه
واقتصاديه صعبه عبد الرحمن المزيني
العربيه لاهور
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
افاد مراسل العربيه مندلاعي مواجهات بين
شبان فلسطينيين وقوات اسرائيليه في منطقه
قبر يوسف شرق نابلس لدى محاولات مستوطنين
اقتحام المنطقه وذكر الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني انه استقبل اصابات بالرصاص
المطاطي وسبعه وخمسين حاله اختناق جراء
الموجهات قبل ان تنسحب القوات الاسرائيليه
في وقت لاحق
[موسيقى]
تنطلق في العاصمه الموريتانيه نواكشوط
الدوره التاسعه والاربعون لمجلس وزراء
الخارجيه بمنظمه التعاون الاسلامي وابحث
المؤتمر على مدى يومين مستجدات القضيه
الفلسطينيه وتطورات الوضع في مالي والساحل
وقضايا الاقليات المسلمه عبر العالم كما
سيتم بحث جهود مواجهه التطرف العنيف
والاسلام وفوبيا
وينضم الينا من نواكشوط مراسل العربيه
ابراهيم مصطفى اهلا بك ابراهيم يعني متى
ستنطلق فعاليات هذا المؤتمر
مرحبا
المؤتمر تنطلق في غضون ساعات او ساعتين
تقريبا
هنا في نواكشوط
المشاركه واسعه
بحضور وجود من السبعة من خمسين دوله هي
الدول الاعضاء في منظمه التعاون الاسلامي
المنظمه اختارت لمؤتمر نواكشوط شعار
الوسطيه والاعتداد صمام الامان
المؤتمر كما سلفت سيبدا في غضون ساعتين
تقريبا
سيفتتحه الرئيس الموريتاني وستكون هناك
كلمه في الجلسه الافتتاحيه
للمؤتمر للامين العام لمنظمه التعاون
الاسلامي
حسين ابراهيم طه
وسيناقش كما تفضلت في المقدمه جمله من
القضايا اهمها الملف الفلسطيني والتطورات
الوضع في مالي والساحل اعتقد هذا الملف
باحواء بالكثير من النقاش لجمله اسباب لان
نواكشوط المضيفه هي
موجوده جغرافيا في منطقه
الساحل ول
ان
منطقه الساحل تشهد منذ فتره
تهديدات ارهابيه جديه
تتفاقم في الاونه الاخيره وتطال
مجموع
دول هذا الاقليم
شكرا
جدد المقيمون الاسرائيليون في المانيا
دعوات التظاهر في برلين مع وصول رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي من يمين نتنياهو الى
العاصمه الالمانيه وقبيل اقلاع الطائراته
الى المانيا الى انه سيبحث بشكل اساسي في
ملف ايران باعتباره الاهم من بين القضايا
التي تهم البلاد مشددا على ان الهواجس
الامنيه تبقى قائمه دوما كما ان زيارته
عرضت الحكومه الالمانيه لضغوط حتى ان
معارضين تنياهو طلبوا من برلين الغاء
الزياره
اعلنت قوه الامم القوى الامم المتحده
المؤقته في لبنان
بان شخص تسلل الى اسرائيل من لبنان مشيره
الى انها لم تلاحظ اي عبور للخط الازرق في
الايام الاخيره كما حدثت الطرفين على ضبط
النفس والحفاظ على الاستقرار دعت ايضا الى
استخدام اليات اليونيفر للتنسيق والارتباط
لتجنب سوء الفهم وتقليل التوترات تتابعنا
بعد الفاصل
مكروم يهدد بحل البرلمان في حال فاشله في
تبني مشروع قانون اصلاح نظام الثقافه
[موسيقى]
ويقول ان المقاتلات الامريكيه ستحلق فوق
البحر الاسود وموسكو تتوعد
وسط تحضيرات دوليه قرابه الطنين ونصف الطن
من اليورانيوم تختفي من ليبيا والحكومه لا
تعلق
تفشي عدوى انهيار سيليكون فالي بنك سيقترض
54 مليار دولار من المركزي السويسري
لليوم التالي على التوالي جلسه استجواب
لحاكم مصرف لبنان رياض سلامه بعد تغيبه عن
الحضور
اهلا بكم من جديد هدد الرئيس الفرنسي اما
نويل ماكرون بحل مجلس النواب في حال فشله
بتبني مشروع قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعدي
وتحدث ماكرون خلال اجتماعه مع رئيسه
الوزراء والوزراء الذين لهم علاقه بقانون
الاصلاح عن ضروره حسم الجدل حول مشروع
القانون ومن المقرر ان يجرى التصويت
النهائي في مجلس النواب على مشروع القانون
المتعلق بالاصلاح التقاعديه يوم الخميس
وذلك على وقع موجه احتجاجات جديده على
المشروع
ايام حاسمه في فرنسا مع اقتراب موعد
التصويت النهائي على مشروع قانون اصلاح
نظام التقاعد الموجه الثامنه من
الاحتجاجات تخرج هذه المره من المربع
الامني في باريس حيث توجد مراكز حساسه مثل
وزاره الخارجيه ومقر البرلمان لذلك رفعت
الشرطه درجه التاهب الامني وقامت باغلاق
هذا الجسر الذي يؤدي الى قصر الاليزي لمنع
المتظاهرين من عبوره الشرطه الفرنسيه صنفت
هذا اليوم بانه يحمل تهديدا عاليا وقالت
مصادر امنيه ان 1400 من مفتعل الشغب
يشاركون في تظاهرات باريس وانه تم نشر
الاف عناصر الشرطه وقرابه 1700 عسكري من
ضمنهم عناصر في الحرس الجمهوري لحمايه
المربع الامني الحشد الامني الكبير حد من
اعمال العنف جزئيا لكنه لم يمنعها
الاشتباكات وقعت مع الشرطه بعد قيام
متظاهرين بتحطيم اللوحات الاعلانيه واشعال
ح اويات القمامه المتكدسه في الشوارع
فاستخدمت الشرطه الغاز المسيل للدموع
واوقعت بعض الاصابات عاد الهدوء فكانت
فرصه بعض المتعبين لاخذ استراحه قصيره
انا متعبه نامل ان يستمع السيد مكروء
الينا لاننا سئمنا انا اتظاهر منذ ان كان
عمري 15 عاما هذا كثير وتعتبر احزاب
اليسار ان المعركه طويله وسيناريو مواصله
التظاهر قائم حتى اذا مر مشروع القانون
اعتقد انه يجب اصلاح نظام التقاعد لكن ليس
بالطريقه التي تقترحها الحكومه وتبدو
الحكومه اقرب الى اعتماد القانون من
الرضوخ لضغط الشارع متسلحه بمواد دستوريه
تسمح بتمريره اذا فشل تصويت مجلس النواب
يوم السادس عشر من مارس فادي الدهوك
العربيه باريس
والى لبنان حيث افادت مراسله العربيه
بوصول حاكم مصرف لبنان الى جلسه التحقيق
معه في قصر العدل ونفت مصادر للعربيه
التقارير حول تقديم حاكم مصرف لبنان رياض
سلامه استقالته تزامنا مع جلسه التحقيق
معه في قضايا اختلاس اموال عامه ومن
المقرر استئناف التحقيق مع سلام اليوم بعد
تاجيرها امس بسبب عدم حضوره ووصف فريق
الدفاع عنه استدعائه للمحاكمه امام قضاه
اوروبيين بانه انتهاك للسياده هذا وطالبت
هيئه القضايا بوزاره العدل اللبنانيه
باعتقال حاكم مصرف لبنان رياض سلامه
غير المشروع وغسل الاموال
وين بدنا نروح يجوا ياخذونا بقى يتذمر
اللبنانيون من ازمه اقتصاديه هي الاسوا في
تاريخ البلاد حلت عليهم في 2019 صنفها
البنك الدولي من بين الاسوا منذ عام
1850 وبينما يغص لبنان بازمه سيوله حاده
تبرز قضيه النصف مليار دولار ونعني بها
قضيه الرياض سلامه حاكم المصرف المركزي
المتهم بالتورط في جرائم رشوه وغسل اموال
واختلاس وتهريب وفي كل مره تتحرك القضيه
ينفي سلامه الادعاءات قائلا انها محاوله
لجعله كبش فداء بسبب الازمه الماليه في
لبنان ومن هذه البوابه كان من المقرر ان
يدخل جلسه تحقيق اوروبيه لكنه تغيب عنها
وعليه ارجات السلطات القضائيه الموعده
للخميس لكن وزاره العدل طالبت بالقبض على
حاكم المصرف المركزي وشقيقه رجا مساعدته
مريم الحويك وحجز املاكهم خمس دول اوروبيه
على الاقل وبقائمه تضم 100 سؤال على ثلاثه
ايام سيتولى طرحها قاضي التحقيق الاول في
بيروت شربل ابو سمره وتركز التحقيقات
الاخيره على العلاقه بين مصرف لبنان وشركه
مسجله في الجزر العذراء يعتقد انها لعبت
دور الوسيط لشراء سندات خزينه عبر تلقي
عموله اكتتاب جرى تحويلها الى حسابات
الرجا سلامه في الخارج وقبل عام اعلنت
وحده التعاون القضائي الاوروبي ان فرنسا
والمانيا و لوكسمبورغ جمدت 120 مليون يورو
من الاصول اللبنانيه اثر تحقيق استهدف
سلامه واربعه من المقربين منه بتهم غسل
اموال بقيمه اكثر من 330 مليون دولار
وخمسه ملايين يورو على التوالي بين 2002 و
ومن بيروت تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه غنوا
ويتيم اهلا بك يا غنوه وانت تتواجدين امام
قصر العدل في بيروت بدات جلسه الاستماع
لحاكم مصرف لبنان رياض سلامه في قضايا
اختلاس بحضوره شخصيا بعد تغيبه امس
صحيح حضر قبل خمس دقائق الى هذه الجلسه
التي كانت قد حضدت في موعد سابقها العاشره
ونصف صباحا بتوقيت بيروت هناك اجراءات
يبدو امنيه مشدده داخل قصر العدل من قبل
من امن الدوله ويوجد ايضا بعض الاجراءات
الامنيه في الخارج كان هناك يعني وجود
للجيش اللبناني في محيط في محيط قصر العدل
تزامنا مع انعقاد هذه الجلسه هذه هي المره
الاولى التي يحدث فيها رياض سلامه شخصيا
الى قاعه استجواب العام الماضي كان هناك
قائد قاضي قاضن بلجيكي حضر الى لبنان
وايضا طالب باستجواب سلامه الذي رفض
الحضور بعدها كان هناك القضاء البلجيكي
قال بانه يعني هناك امكانيه لاستجواب
سلامه في بلجيكا بدلا من لبنان ولكن يبدو
ان بعدها قام القضاء اللبناني باتخاذ قرار
منع سفر بحق رياض سلامه وبذلك لم يذهب
لاستجوابه هناك اذا هي المره الاولى بعد
محاولات متعدده
يعني يعني لعدم الحضور الى هذه
الاستجوابات علما ان رياض سلامه اليوم هو
حاضر في هذه الجلسه كمستمع اليه لاتخاذ
بعض المعلومات منه حول قضايا كما ذكرتم
تبيض اموال واختلاس وغيرها من التي تقدم
بها القضاء الاوروبي غنوه كنا سمعنا من
ورائك احد المحتجين امام قصر العدل هل
هناك افراد اخرين من الناس يعني التي
تحتاج
عدد قليل جدا يعني اعتقد يعني لا يتعدى
الخمسه اشخاص حضروا صباحا الى الى محيط
قصر العدل وهؤلاء عاده يكونون متواجدون
دائما في التظاهرات التي تكون ضد المصارف
وضد حاكم مصرف لبنان خاصه في ظل الازمه
الاقتصاديه التي يعيشها لبنان منذ خمس منذ
خمسه اعوام والاجراءات التي يتخذها رياض
سلامه منذ بدء هذه الازمه هم يعتبرون انه
ليس فقط مسؤول عن هدر اموال اللبنانيين هو
ايضا يعني المسؤولين في لبنان وعن اختلاس
الاموال بل ايضا ان الاجراءات التي تم
اتخاذها خلال الاعوام الماضيه التعاميم
التي اصدرها حاكم مصرف لبنان زادت من عمق
هذه الازمه غنوه هل هناك من معلومات حول
كم جلسه استماع سيخضع لها حاكم مصرف لبنان
الحديث هو عن 100 سؤال تقدمت بالوفد
القضائي الوفد القضائي الاوروبي لا يوجد
معلومات محدده حول عدد الجلسات ممكن ان
يكونوا ثلاثه جلسات ولكن ايضا يمكن ان
يكونوا اكثر من ذلك علما ان رياض سليمه
كانك قد حاول عدم الحضور امس بذريعه بان
هذا هذه الاستجوابات تمس بالسياده
اللبنانيه وهو ما رفضته النيابه العامه
التمييزيه
القاضي شرب ابو سمره الذي يقوم باستجواز
اليوم هو قال بان اي سؤال يمس قال للعربيه
بان اي سؤال يمس بالسياده اللبنانيه لن
يطرحه لن يطرحه على سلامه طبعا هذه
الاسئله كان قد وضعها القضاء الاوروبي
مهمه القاضي اللبناني اليوم هو فقط طرح
هذه الاسئله على رياض سليمي لانه لا يحق
للقضاء الاوروبي بطرحها ولكن بالطبع يحق
له بطلب هذه
الاستجوابات خاصه وان هناك معاهده لبنانيه
لمعاهده دوليه لمكافحه الفساد كان لبنان
قد وقع عليها شكرا جزيلا لك غنوه يتيم
مراسله العربيه من بيروت
عقد رئيس مجلس السياده وقائد القوات
المسلحه السودانيه عبد الفتاح البرهان
ونائبه محمد حمدان دقلو حميدتي مع القوى
السياسه الموقع على الاتفاق الايطالي
اجتماعا لمناقشه سير العمليه السياسيه في
البلاد وبحسب البيان فان الاطراف العسكريه
والمدنيه اعلنت توافقها على اسس ومبادئ
الاصلاح المدني الاصلاح الامني والعسكري
وعزمها تجاوز التفاصيل الفنيه العالقه كما
اتفقت الاطراف على الدعوه لانعقاد اليا
سياسيه لتعجيل والبدء بعملها لصياغه مسوده
الاتفاق السياسي النهائي بدوره كشف الناطق
الرسمي باسم العمليه السياسيه خالد عمر
يوسف ان الاطراف المجتمعه توافقت على اسس
ومبادئ الاصلاح الامني والعسكري وعلى
عزمها تجاوز ما تبقى من نقاشات فنيه كما
اتفقت الاطراف على انهاء مؤتمري العداله
والعداله الانتقاليه والاصلاح الامنيه
والعسكريه قبل بدايه رمضان بالاضافه الى
ما سبق اتفق المجتمعون على الدعوه لانعقاد
اليه سياسيه تبدا عملها بصوره عاجله
لصياغه مسوده الاتفاق السياسي النهائي
الحدد الاجتماع يعني خرج بمخرجات مهمه
ولاها الاكمال المناقشات حول القضيتين
المتبقيتين قضيه الاعداد الانتقاليه
والاصلاح الامن العسكريه عبره
المتفق عليها قبل حلول شهر رمضان الكريم
ان شاء الله في ظرف الاسبوع القادم وايضا
ان تقوم العاليه الثلاثيه بتوجيه الدعوه
لاليه سياسيه من القوى
الموقعه والقوه غير الموقعه المتفق عليها
من اجل ان تشرع فورا في صياغه مشروع
الاتفاق النهائي وان تعمل اللجنه
التنسيقيه المشتركه بين القوى الموقعه
والاليه الثلاثيه على وضع جدول زمني
بالمهام المتبقيه بحيث انه يتم الفراغ من
كل المهام المتبقيه وتوقيع الاتفاق
النهائي في اسرع وقت ممكن يعني تتواصل
اجتماعات التنسيقيه المشتركه في الايام
القادمه
على مدار اليوم من اجل الاسراع في اكمال
ما تبقى من الخطوات
وانضم الينا من الخرطوم مراسل العربيه
سالم الهاشمي اهلا بك معنا سالم يعني وقع
هذا الاجتماع الذي حصل امس على الشارع
السوداني
نعم اهلا بك وبكل المشاهدين تباينت الاراء
حول هذا الاجتماع ونتائجه قوى الحريه
والتغيير وحتى المشاركين في هذا الاجتماع
منهم ياسر العلمان القيادي بالحريه
والتغيير وكذلك كما العمر القيادي
بالمؤتمر الشعبي ايضا من المشاركين في هذا
الاجتماع اي القوه الموقعه الاتفاق رحبت
بهذا الاجتماع ورات ان فيه خطوه لحل
الاشكال الذي كان يتم تداوله في الايام
الماضيه ما بين الدعم السريع والجيش وان
هذه خطوه جيده خاصه ببدايه الورشه التي
ستنطلق اليوم في الجانب الاخر هو الحريه
والتغيير الكتله الديمقراطيه على لسان مني
اركوب هنداوي رفضت هذا الاجتماع ورات انه
خطوه غير جيده وانه لا يمضي بالبلاد
للامام انه ربما يوصف بقصف قفز في الظلام
دون النظر الى واقع الحال لكن بشكل عام
هذا الاجتماع المهم فيه الان هو موضوع
الجدول الزمنيه فيما يتعلق في بقيه الورش
والاتفاق النهائي الذي ذكر الذي
ينتظر بعده ان تشكل حكومه مدنيه ديمقراطيه
كما يصفها الموقعون على الاتفاق الايطالي
شكرا جزيلا لك سالم الهاشمي من الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
شهد سوق العملات سواء ابرز الدولار واليان
اقبالا كبيرا وسط مخاوف من حدوث ازمه
مصرفيه عالميه بعد انتقال تاثير انهيار
بنك سيليكون فالي بالولايات المتحده عبر
المحيط الاطلسي الى بنك ردي سويس بسويسرا
الذي هوت اسومه الى النسبه بلغت 30%
مضطوره لاقتراض ما يصل الى 54 مليار دولار
من البنك المركزي السويسري لمواجهه الازمه
واصل الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه
مناورات اهمال عسكريه المشتركه واجرى قوات
البلدين تدريبات في الهواء الطلق التماثل
عمليات هجوم جوي كجزء من هذه المناورات
التي اطلق عليها اسم درع الحريه 23 وهي
الاكبر من نوعها منذ خمس سنوات
[موسيقى]
نهايه النشره تذكرون بالعناوين
يتحدى الروس ويقول ان المقاتلات الامريكيه
ستحلق فوق البحر الاسود وموسكو تتوعد
وسط تحضيرات دوليه قرابه الطنين ونصف الطن
من اليورانيوم تختفي من ليبيا والحكومه لا
تعلق
تفشي عدوى انهيار سيليكون فالي بنك ريدي
سويس سيقترض 54 مليار دولار من المركز
السويسري
بدءوا جلسه استجواب لحاكم مصرف لبنان رياض
سلامه بحضوره شخصيا وسط اجراءات امنيه
مشدده
العربيه للمزيد من الاخبار الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]